bonjour à tous et bienvenue à bruxelles
nous sommes comme toujours au coeur du
parlement européen pour ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo et dans cette
émission nous irons en grèce où le
gouvernement vous le savez à fermer la
télévision publique
alors s'agit-il d'une atteinte à la
démocratie ou d'une nécessaire réforme
la méthode en tout cas a choqué toute
l'europe l'actualité c'est aussi le
lancement des négociations commerciales
entre l'europe et les états unis dans ce
dossier paris a tout fait pour défendre
son exception culturelle
barack obama pour les états unis
josé manuel barroso pour l'union
européenne
au milieu des lacs d'irlande du nord en
marge du g8
les représentants des deux géants
économiques ont donné le coup d'envoi de
négociations historiques entre les deux
continents
objectif créer la plus vaste zone de
libre échange au monde non aujourd'hui
avec le président obama nous avons lancé
cet accord très important de libre
échange et d'investissement ce contrat
s'il se fait et de loin le plus
important jamais mis en place cet accord
vise à baisser les droits de douane
entre bruxelles et washington et à
ouvrir des marchés aux entreprises
implantées des deux côtés de
l'atlantique de quoi changer la donne
face aux pays émergents et surtout face
à la chine
les partenariats union européenne états
unis et le plus riche au monde il
représente presque la moitié du pib
mondial avec environ 1000 milliards de
dollars en biens et services chaque
année mais de nombreux sujets de
contentieux sont au menu de la
régulation financière à la protection
des données personnelles en passant par
les ogm
plus embarrassant le bras de fer qui
oppose paris à bruxelles la france a
obtenu in extremis que le secteur
audiovisuel soit exclu du mandat des
négociations au nom de l'exception
culturelle que paris veut défendre de la
toute puissance des plateformes
américaines comme google dans une
interview à un quotidien anglophone josé
manuel barroso a dénoncé une attitude
totalement réactionnaire à lui
on indirecte aux menaces françaises de
veto répond surprise de françois
hollande
je ne peux pas croire que le président
de la commission européenne ait pu tenir
de tels propos sur la france mais le
commissaire européen karel de gucht qui
est chargée des négociations assure que
l'exclusion de l'audiovisuel n'est que
provisoire et la position française est
loin de faire l'unanimité en europe nous
sommes cette semaine avec jean luc
bennahmias bonjour jean réputé européens
vont siéger ici au sein de l'alliance
des démocrates et des libéraux pour
l'europe s'intéresser à beaucoup de
choses et notamment relations franco
américaines europe et entre l'europe et
l'amérique
alors la france s'est battue et continue
de se battre pour défendre l'exception
culturelle
est ce que c'est un combat français ou
un combat français est de toute façon le
sujet sur cet accord union européenne
états unis au niveau du commerce
international et des marges extérieur du
commerce extérieur sera le sujet central
de mon point de vue des prochaines
élections européennes en 2014
donc on a de quoi débattre il faut même
débattre en toute transparence et pour
la sanza n'est pas transparent alors
séparé actionnaires cédants progressiste
tout ça n'est pas transparent on a eu
quelques bribes de résolutions qu'on a
voté au parlement à strasbourg il ya
quelques jours
moi je me suis abstenu parce que
justement il n'y a pas assez de
transparence ça débat fondamental
comment vous avez apprécié la petite
phrase de josé manuel barroso alors il
dit que ce n'était pas destiné à la
france mais on a bien compris le message
ça commence très mal je suis ses jeux
sur leurs roseaux guinée qui manque
souvent quand même d'un certain courage
par rapport à toutes les politiques à
mener notamment au niveau de l'union
européenne même si je sois il semblait
avoir fait quelques progrès alors là
cette phrase-là idée est complètement
stupide
il met de l'huile sur le feu là où il y
en a vraiment pas besoin je vous le dis
ce sera le débat central en tout cas en
france ce sera le débat central sur cet
accord union européenne états unis pas
la peine de mettre de l'huile sur le feu
qu'est-ce qu'on veut défendre alors il
ya l'exception culturelle et ça ne
suffit pas tout ce qui est politique
évidemment audiovisuelle mais il ya
aussi l'agroalimentaire il
là commence on fait par rapport aux
services publics il ya aussi comment on
fait par rapport à tout ce qui est
agriculteur et on sait bien que entre
les notions d'agriculture en france en
europe et aux etats-unis c'est pas la
même chose
la commission européenne dit redouter
des mesures de rétorsion avant l'heure
de la part des états unis qui serait
infondé de dire eh bah dans ce cas nous
aussi on va négocier des dérogations
seraient pas déjà le cas
les indignés ne protège pas leur
industrie ne protège pas leur commerce
nôtre c'est ça le rend heureux
tout ce qui est leur permet d'exister
bien sûr qu'ils le font et moi je dis à
l'union européenne ne le faisons pas
assez
donc vous dites l'europe doit être plus
forte parce qu'il ya quand même des
risques de qu'elles soient sont qu'elles
subissent encore plus l'invasion
américaine non pour la région américaine
je pense que l'europe je suis déjà
beaucoup trop facilement on se donne au
niveau de l'europe et c'est très bien
des réglementations extrêmement forte
réglementation reach sur les produits
chimiques des réglementations
extrêmement forte et où des directives
sur la santé sur l'environnement mais
tout ce qui vient de l'extérieur on ne
contrôle pas je dis que ça n'est pas
possible
le ski est sorti dernièrement sur les
accords union européenne par rapport aux
panneaux photovoltaïques par rapport à
la chine
c'est un petit début de faire attention
quand même à ce que ce que nous mettons
nous en règlement et en directives de
manière extrêmement forte soit aussi le
cas dans les produits qui arrivent deux
continents autres états unis chine
brésil voilà il s'agit non pas d'un
protectionnisme au sens réactionnaire du
terme
il s'agit de voir comment nous défendons
au niveau de l'union européenne notre
industrie notre commerce
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
l'union européenne des institutions
européennes ont les moyens justement de
défendre ses intérêts européens face à
la toute puissance de pays comme les
etats-unis ou la chine
si elle s'en donner les moyens l'union
européenne en auraient les moyens ça
passera d'abord par une union de
politiques qui ne voient pas si c'est
d'accord et dans ce cadre là c'est pas
un débat franco européen c'est un débat
de savoir est ce que le
l'union européenne est qu un libre
marché dans une concurrence faussée et
non libres n'ont pas libre et non
faussée mail inverse où est-ce qu'on se
donne les moyens politiques
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
débat entre la france et l'allemagne qui
ne sont à ce niveau là il ya des choses
vraiment un faux faut progresser
d'autres grands pays comme l'italie
l'espagne la pologne doivent rentrer
aussi dans ce débat je n'oublie personne
mais ces grands pays de se mettre
d'accord sur une union politique
économique qui passe de mon point de vue
par une fiscalité progrès
progressivement commune dès le départ et
vous voyez on en est malheureusement
très loin c'est tant qu'on sera sur un
marché ouvert à tout va clairement les
choses sont mal définis mais vous pensez
que c'est une bonne chose de l'union
européenne signent avec les etats-unis
ce traité de libre échange sont qu'est
ce que l'europe
aïe aïe gagner mais on serait et gagner
si l'europe l'union européenne tv
véritable politique économique fiscale
de manière unifiée sur les grands pays
que je viens de citer
je pense que ce serait oui et tout à y
gagner c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les
déséquilibres sont gigantesques
les états unis je comprends bien
monsieur obama lui défend son point de
vue ça n'empêche pas que les intérêts
américains et les intérêts américains
c'est un objet qui passe par lui tu dois
ça certain protectionnisme
il ne s'en cache pas par rapport à leur
industrie bon clairement il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que des accords de ce
genre
s'ils sont transparents et si l'union
européenne existe réellement elle n'est
pas uniquement un conglomérat d'état
nation aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement
souvent un conglomérat d'état nation
alors jean-luc bennahmias union
européenne est en discussions avec les
états unis sur un autre sujet très
sensible à cyber surveillance le
renseignement américain assemblerait
puiser dans les données de facebook ou
google pour surveiller les
communications des citoyens américains
ou étrangers et même européen
le sujet a fait la une des télévisions
d'europe regardez
l'information a été dévoilée par le
quotidien britannique the guardian
en vertu d'une ordonnance de justice
secrète l'opérateur téléphonique verizon
remettrait chaque jour à l' agence
nationale de sécurité des renseignements
sur des millions de citoyens américains
le cadre politique légal de la
surveillance électronique est un sujet
très complexe mais pour edouard snowdon
la collecte massive de données de
communication constituent une violation
inacceptable de la vie privée là est née
sa cible les communications de n'importe
qui elle traite les données par défaut
elle les recueils dans son système
les filtres et les stocks accès pendant
trois mois aux données du programme
ultra secret prise homme qui existe
depuis 2008 et qui collectent des
informations provenant des emails de
pages web d'historique de recherches et
de données de téléphonie en tête à la
panique ce sont des données que
détiennent les géants microsoft google
ou encore facebook
nous avons toujours agi conformément à
la loi répond facebook assurant avoir
rejeté de nombreuses requêtes des
autorités les responsables du réseau
social indique qu'en six mois il avait
reçu près de 10 mille demandes
d'information un chiffre que facebook
met en perspective avec son milliard
d'utilisateurs une façon de minimiser
l'ampleur du scandale
que les choses soient claires ces droits
fondamentaux des citoyens ne sont pas
négociables
mais bien sûr les gouvernements doivent
aussi se soucier de la sécurité
nationale jean luc bennahmias
l'espionnage a toujours fait partie des
règles du jeu internationales sans
remonter jusqu'à mazarin
aujourd'hui c'est avec les moyens
modernes les technologies nouvelles
est ce que c'est si surprenant que ça
dans les états unis nous écoute
non non tout le monde paie tout le monde
les hackers existe ne tourne c'est bien
que la technologie que sur les réseaux
sociaux fait que tout est absolument
enfin peut-être transparent voilà alors
après est-ce qu'on se donne les
régulations nécessaires pour essayer de
maîtriser tout cela je pense que ça doit
être le cas mais je pense que même si on
met tout ce qu'on peut en forme pour
maîtriser tout cela il y aura toujours
possibilité pour tel gouvernement tel
état où une telle puissance autres
d'aller fouiller dans nos réseaux
sociaux il ya un projet de directive
pour mieux protéger les données
personnelles c'est le portefeuille de
madame reding parce que ça en est ce
qu'aujourd'hui mais les aléas les moyens
de la garantir la protection de la vie
privée des citoyens
madame reding fils travaille je pense
qu'elle le fait en toute honnêteté
puisque ça suffit je ne crois pas est ce
qu'une réglementation suivi par rapport
à ça je ne crois pas non plus parce que
ces sont des réseaux transparent dans
lesquels on peut rentrer si on est un
peu plus technologiquement malin on peut
y rentrer bon après qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait comment moi pendant le principal
est de savoir si on demande à un moment
donné d'effacer effacés c'est difficile
parce que ça reste en stock mais quand
même d'effacer
c'est tout le problème de facebook 1 par
rapport notamment à lausanne ots les
sens ou par rapport aux personnes qui
ont mis sur facebook un ensemble de
choses qui étaient plus de leur vie
privée que leur vie publique
comment on fait je crois que m il faut
donc se donner les directives
nécessaires ça ne changera pas au bout
du compte de toute façon un certain
nombre de choses stocker resteront
stockés dans un monde très
dématérialisés comme vous dites est ce
que les frontières électroniques ont
encore une valeur
vous dites que je crois pas je crois pas
on a inventé tout ça on a des systèmes
qui sont dignes de de ce genre de la
science-fiction on est en plein dedans
c'est plus de la science-fiction sait
discerner dans la science technologique
et dans la technologie scientifique
totalement je vous dis c'est simplement
le droit à l'oubli doit exister sur la
méthode utilisée par les états unis
alors que washington a accepté
d'informer les européens d'échanger des
informations avec eux sur ce fameux
programme surveillance prises hommes
votre collègue françoise castex a
répondu qu'il s'agissait d'une mascarade
une fois de plus la commission
européenne ce fait le supplétif des
intérêts américains dit elle
vous êtes du même avis je ne dirais pas
comme ça je suis du même avis françoise
castex qu'à raison bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr tant que nous ne sommes pas
nous on capacité d'avoir une union
européenne on le dit régulièrement qui
soit unifiée en tout cas collectivement
unifier un certain nombre de pays
bien sûr chacun défend son petit bout de
gras état nation par la nation on voit
bien en ce moment que les conseils
européens successivement ont du mal à se
mettre d'accord sur quoi que ce soit
rien ne sort et quand quand est-ce
qu'elle sera qu'elle sera enfin d'accord
quand est ce que cette union parce qu'il
va enfin voir le jour alors même que la
chine affirme sa toute puissance sur la
scène internationale les états unis
renforcent à l'heure le jour où la
france et l'allemagne et je n'ai pas et
je ne différencie pas les comment dire
les côtés négatifs des différents pays
la france jouant du franches les
français font souvent du franchouillard
jeu sera pas l'exception culturelle
là c'est plus qu'utile mais je parle du
reste l'allemagne parfois se se prend
trop au sérieux le jour où la france et
l'allemagne décideront à m'abandonner
d'avoir une fiscalité commune d'avoir
des politiques économiques communes des
politiques industrielles communes une
politique extérieure et de défense
commune
ce jour là
en partant de la france et de
l'allemagne à ça donc douze pays italie
espagne portugal pologne dire on écoute
et on veut bien se mettre d'accord avec
vous et on aura une union européenne
réellement et fédéralistes et politique
qui permettra de négocier de manière
égale et tout à fait équitable et égal
avec états unis et chine qui sont pas
les ennemis qui sont des gens qui
défendent leur bout dehors d'un jour
peut-être merci beaucoup
jean luc bennahmias d'avoir commenté
l'actualité pour nous on va parler
maintenant de la grèce françois bonnet
sera avec une député grec pour parler de
l'incroyable décision de fermer la
télévision publique décision annulée en
début de semaine par le conseil d'état
du pays
jérémy hartmann a passé 48 heures avec
les salariés mobilisés au coeur de la
tourmente reportage
comme un petit air de woodstock dans les
chaudes soirées d'athènes avec la
coupure de la diffusion de la télé
publique grecque
ils étaient des milliers jeunes vieux
familles avec enfants à se retrouver
devant le siège de le rt dans une
ambiance à la fois festive et combative
le gouvernement à couper la diffusion
des chaînes publiques
avec une telle brutalité une telle
violence ce ne sont pas des méthodes
dignes d'une démocratie c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on est là pour essayer de sauver
notre démocratie un soutien aux 2600
fonctionnaires qui se retrouvaient au
chômage sans préavis dont près de 600
journalistes
ça fait trois ans que je suis au chômage
je sais ce que ça veut dire si nous
sommes là c'est pour une chose la
solidarité la solidarité il ya encore la
solidarité
personne ne devrait rester laissés pour
compte dans son combat
la foule compacte comme un bouclier
humain autour du bâtiment
de quoi redonner du baume au coeur aux
journalistes et techniciens qui se sont
relayés nuit et jour à l'intérieur avec
l'énergie du désespoir
ils ont continué à fournir des
programmes diffusés sur des sites
internet confidentielles vous savez on
dort très peu on travaille 20 heures par
jour on est en direct on donne des
interviews à la presse étrangère sans
savoir ce qu'on va devenir
mais je suis aussi soulagé ça peut
paraître étonnant mais le climat était
tellement irrespirable ces dernières
semaines ont travaillé comme des fous
pour 1200 euros par mois et en plus on
devait rendre des comptes
non c'était devenu invivable
atmosphère pesante ressentie par
l'ensemble du personnel car le rt c'est
aussi un coeur et deux orchestres
symphoniques claire violoncelliste
française y travaille depuis près de 20
ans ya deux orchestres et un choeur qui
disparaissent du jour au lendemain c'est
le meilleur coeur de graisse qui
collabore non pas seulement avec nous
mais aussi avec leur caisse nationale
régulièrement
voilà c'est fermé trois trucs comme ça
c'est pas une vitrine qui se ferme c'est
un gros pan de la vie culturelle
d'athènes la stratégie de l'écran noir
procédé choquant pour certains mal
nécessaire pour d'autres alors que
l'union européenne la bce et le fmi
réclame la suppression de 2000 postes de
fonctionnaires avant fin juin
la porte-parole de nouvelle démocratie
le parti majoritaire de la coalition au
pouvoir assumer parfaitement ce week-end
encore la décision du premier ministre
antonis samaras depuis une dizaine
d'années la façon de fonctionner de la
télé d'état est un luxe que la grèce ne
peut plus payer toutes les tentatives de
réforme de l'audiovisuel public ont
échoué l'écran noir ça symbolise la fin
de la corruption et de l'opacité
si le gouvernement s'est engagé à
assurer un service minimum de
l'information avant de rebâtir un
audiovisuel public plus transparent le
pays est resté privé l'information
pendant plusieurs jours et pour de
nombreux journalistes grecs les
arguments du gouvernement relevait
plutôt de la propagande d'état
en guise de riposte la rédaction de ce
journal indépendant a décidé de publier
un numéro exceptionnel et criait
imprimés presque bénévolement cette
parution spontanée a été envoyée aux
quatre coins de grèce avec les moyens du
bord et distribué sur place auprès des
manifestants athéniens d'abord
l'audiovisuel
public a été salement censure et on ne
sait pas s'il va revoir le jour un beau
soir on s'est retrouvés ne plus avoir
d'image à ne plus recevoir que des infos
de chaînes privées les informations pas
forcément fiables
au delà des suppressions de postes de
fonctionnaires la fermeture programmée
de la radio télévision publique
c'était d'abord pour ces manifestants un
contre-pouvoir en moins dans une
démocratie en crise tard cette nuit là
il reprenait en choeur un chant
emblématique de la résistance grecque
ultime façon de faire entendre leur voix
un reportage à athènes signé jeremy
hartmann alors nous sommes avec annie
petit matin bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne vous êtes grec vice
présidente du parlement européen et vous
êtes socialiste quand on vient de voir
ce qui s'est passé et ce qui est
toujours en train d'ailleurs de se
passer à la télévision grecque même si
peut-être est-elle en train de rouvrir
est ce que vous diriez que c'est la
démocratie qui est en jeu dans votre
pays
absolument c'est la démocratie qui est
en risque ça c'est très clair que ce
soit sur la procédure qui a été
décidée par une partie du gouvernement
tripartite notamment par le parti
conservateur de la nouvelle démocratie
par le premier ministre samaras la
procédure était choquant
ils ont fait une décision sous la forme
d'un décret présidentiel il l'annonçait
midi la semaine dernière et au bout de
11 heures ils ont procédé à la fermeture
de
de la télévision publique grecque donc
la procédure d choquant c'était
clairement une l'entente unilatérale
c'était pas démocratique du tout il n'y
a pas eu de balles parlement grec
il n'y a même pas eu une décision en ce
sens du gouvernement
parmi les trois partis qui forment le
gouvernement de coalition actuelle une
décision autoritaire voire autoritariste
ce que vous direz vous connaissez la
télévision grecque parce que vous y avez
travaillez vous étiez journaliste et
correspondant à paris à paris est-ce qu
il est vrai que la télévision grecque
est irréformable non je ne crois pas je
crois par contre qu'il y ait nécessité
absolue pour réformer pour restructurer
la télévision grecque
en général les secteurs publics grecs
mais je devrai marque à faire d'abord le
système politique surtout le parti
conservateur qui découvre tout à coup
aujourd'hui que les télévisions grecques
se trouve dont la situation des crises
dont votre reportage
donc en tant qu'homme télévision
surpeuplée gonflé à crédible et c'est
moi je dis qu'il faut d'abord
reconnaître nos propres responsabilités
autant que système politique parce que
c'est le système politique
traditionnelle en grec en grèce social
de l'association aura lieu au sud huit à
u2 attitude clientéliste à l'égard de la
télévision publique grecque donc il ya
eu des décisions pour faire des gens
travailler là bas qu'ils étaient
amicale aux gouvernements de chaque fois
tout ça et sur des choses qu'il faut
changer quel est l'objectif du premier
ministre samaras est ce que c'est
vraiment de changer la télévision
publique grecque il n'y arrivait pas
parce que des réformes n'arrivait pas à
se faire ou est-ce que ça va plus loin
que ça et c'est un message envoyé en dix
ans en battant des si vous faites pas ce
qu'on veut vous voyez qu'on a là
suffisamment tôt s'ils voulaient
vraiment réformer la télévision grecque
il a un projet de réforme qui est très
concret très crédible très valable
dans son tiroir c'est le projet que lui
même en tant que chef de l'opposition
grecque a combattu très fortement au
moment qu'il a que ce projet était
présenté
c'était la période du gouvernement
papadimos et c'était le ministre
mossialos à l'époque qui a procédé dès
lors il aurait pu faire autrement il
aurait pu il aurait pu implémenter ces
projets qui parler clairement de
réduction du de taille du secteur trade
mais étape par étape
est ce que est ce que c'est vraiment le
gouvernement qui est responsable de
cette fermeture
ou est ce que c'est la troïka moi je
crois qu'il ya une combinaison de
responsables il était d'abord je je fais
confiance c'est ce que les institutions
la commission reprend surtout disent que
c'était une décision autonome du
gouvernement grec
c'était une décision pas même du
gouvernement je le répète une partie du
gouvernement mais de l'autre côté je
crois que cette décision était forcée
d'une certaine façon de sous la pression
de l'achèvement de
du programme des grandes heures du mans
- d'or etc etc
il y a eu le gouvernement grec a pris un
engagement pour 2000 sorties du secteur
public jusqu'à la fin du moins de juin
ils n'ont pas pu malheureusement mettre
en place un projet d'évaluation et des
réductions crédible concret donc qu'ils
arrivent au bout de la fin du mois de
juin sans avoir ces projets en place
elles ont procédé à cette décision
autoritaire de fermer la télévision
publique pour pouvoir donner à troïka
c'est ce qu'ils voulaient le demi
personne c'est pas la troïka sur le
bouton b et les conséquences
vous êtes d'une députée européenne
est-ce que vous avez été satisfaites par
la réaction des autorités européennes
par exemple la commission europe et
européennes qui a dit effectivement
c'est une décision du gouvernement c'est
pas nous qui avons demandé qu'ils
ferment était un jouet pas je n'étais
pas satisfaite de la réaction des
institutions surtout de la commission
parce que j'étais très satisfaite de la
réaction du président du parlement
européen de monsieur schulz qui envoyait
lettres se disent qu'il est socialiste
mais qu'il a un rôle institutionnel
actuellement et qui l'envoyaient en
lettres en lui demandant de reconsidérer
sa décision la commission rappelle la
réaction très ambigu c'était très
content de la réaction des collègues de
médias européens et de plusieurs
capitales notamment la france c'est ce
que je suis moi même en parlant à la
plénière
a strasbourg la semaine passée c'est
qu'il s'agit à mon avis de tolérer un
tel déficit telles violations de
procédures démocratiques fondamentales
pays membres de l'union européenne
membres de la zone euro
c'est pas un problème grec à mon avis
c'est un problème c'est un problème est
européen et c'est un problème qui est
lié à mon avis avec la façon qu'on a
géré la crise de la zone euro jusqu'à
présent on doit comprendre
est-ce que vous pensez que justement il
va il pourrait y avoir un impact qu'il
ya des élections par exemple européenne
parce que ça peut avoir un à ce qui
s'est passé avec la télévision grecque
est ce que ça peut avoir un impact sur
les élections européennes est partout en
europe
est ce que par exemple les citoyens
européens ne serait pas en train de se
dire ce que vous dites c'est à dire
finalement cette europe là n'est pas si
démonstratif pouvait l'être en tout cas
on a déjà des signes très alerte ans
en suivant le eurobaromètre on voit très
clairement qu'une majorité de citoyens
européens
presque partout en europe ne plus de
confiance
aux institutions à seulement
institutions je dirais même au projet
européen le projet européen a perdu son
sont sans gloire sa valeur il faut re
convaincre les citoyens que l'europe
c'est pour que l'europe ça vaut la peine
pour faire cela il faut que les
décisions prises à l'échelle européenne
passe un signe clair aux citoyens
comprends leur intérêt en considération
donc ça veut dire le coût de la crise il
faut pas que le citoyen normal assume la
partie principale est la démocratie la
démocratie c'est essentiel on peut pas
procéder à faire des réformes comme
celles exigence sans respecter dans les
urnes
peut-être de cette crise réelle euros là
ce sera donc l'année prochaine lors des
élections européennes anni podimata
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
c'est la fin d'europe hebdo on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine avec
kathia gilder et d'ici là bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires